We starting today,
uh,
on,
um,
how many ways,
uh,
for whom the bell tolls.
And,
um,
as is frequently the case,
the title comes from a very well known classic in this case,
John Donne's home.
Um,
which essentially included in the text of phoned about hose.
So you guys can just go on and read it on your own.
But I just thought that we'll talk about it together a little bit.
Um,
the very famous phrase from a very famous poem,
no man is an island and time of itself.
Each case appears of the continent a part of the main,
if a clod be washed away by the sea,
Europe is the last,
each man's death diminish me from involved in manly,
therefore send not for whom the bell tolls,
it tolls for thee.
Um,
so a number of issues come up in this poem,
justly famous poem,
um,
that we're not,
even though we have separate bodies,
um,
Dan's argument and in fact,
throughout his entire poetic Corpus,
um,
is that our separate bodies,
uh,
in some sense and kind of optical illusion and also experiential illusion as
well.
We feel that we're just one unit,
but we actually tied in so many different ways to other people.
So the death of other people,
um,
with diminish me in the sense that those ties will be cut when those people die.
But also this,
uh,
more disturbing sense that uh,
the manner of death of other people is in some sense also a kind of a prelude
and analogy and a suggestion of the way that we would die.
Um,
so the bell is tolling for someone else right now,
but sooner or later it's going to toll for myself,
for you and me.
Um,
so it's,
um,
dev is central is absolutely central with is not the two for him develop those.
It is not just a general argument about importance of interconnections is really
about how the interconnections and death and no other,
uh,
whereby Hemingway's so centrally and meditating on the phenomenon of dying and
what it means to die a good death.
So we'll come back to this.
Um,
but today we,
that wouldn't be the focus today.
Um,
and instead today we'll be talking mostly about the Spanish civil war,
which is a very important context for this novel.
Um,
and it's very important to get some historical facts under our belts.
So basically the two sides of the Spanish civil war,
other Republicans and the national risk,
um,
the Republican's are sometimes referred to as the loyalists.
And this phrase is sometimes because it suggests that maybe the loyalists are on
the right,
but this is actually not the case.
The Republicans,
uh,
on the whole,
on the left,
um,
but they are loyal to the legitimately elected government.
Um,
the Spanish republic,
uh,
had a,
had an elected government,
um,
and so the loyalists were loyal to that.
They were protecting the Spanish republic.
And the reason we know that they are on the left is that,
uh,
they're back my Mexico,
which is understand the vogue given the Spanish connection.
Um,
but they were also backed by the Soviet Union,
so that lots of references to Russians in this novel,
from Russian planes to Russian cigarettes to the restrooms at the hotel,
gay lots.
So lots and lots of Russians.
The Russian general,
um,
is the opening pages of the novel.
So,
um,
the Soviet Union
was a central presence,
um,
in his novel.
Uh,
but more than that,
the reason that the Spanish civil war has gone down in history is such an
important war,
um,
is that was supported by 30,000 international volunteers making up the
international brigades,
including people from Poland,
France,
England,
and loss of volunteers from the United States.
So the United States volunteers,
we call it Abraham,
Abraham Lincoln Brigade.
Um,
and then,
so all this is on the republican side,
on the side of the Spanish republic.
Um,
and then opposing that,
fighting that and eventually,
um,
triumph and prevailing over them,
uh,
would be the nationalist.
Um,
in this novel,
Hemingway does not refer to the nationalists as the national list would never
comes up.
He refers to them as fast as,
um,
and the,
the world sort of pejorative rang now that it seems as if he's condemning them
ahead of time.
But actually,
um,
in the 1930s fascist was just neutral.
Would,
that was the party,
the fascist party.
So,
um,
even though now historians were referred to that size,
the nationalist side,
um,
in the,
in my lectures have been referring to them as fast as just because that's the
word the Hemingway uses.
Um,
and the fascists were backed by Germany and Italy.
so we see lots of German planes as well,
Italian lanes as well.
Um,
and the victory of the fascist let to the dictatorship of general Franco who
would go on to rule Spain for many years.
Um,
so we know the outcome of that wall and there's a very tragic outcome according
to many people.
Um,
the,
one of the great photographers of the war,
uh,
was Robert Kappa.
Um,
and fortunately many of his images are now available there in the public domain.
So this is Robert Cap photographing the Spanish civil war.
And this is the most iconic image,
um,
is 1936 the death of a loyalist Republican soldier.
Um,
and most of,
um,
campus pictures tend to be about the death of just one person.
Um,
very,
um,
kind of those visceral reaction to the death of that person.
Um,
and,
uh,
kind of blurry as well because that's probably how death we're feel when it
comes to us,
is now we don't have a very distinct sensation,
um,
of that condition when we're going through it.
Um,
at least that's,
I think that that's the rationale behind that,
other than also the fact that he was just on site taking the picture right
there.
Um,
here is,
um,
and other picture by Robert Kappa again now I think though the six to the very
beginning of the war,
um,
and these people were just college students.
This was university city Madrid.
Um,
most of the people who fought in the Spanish who are civil,
Ian's,
um,
they were just students.
Lots of women as like this is one known for their presence of women,
um,
fighting.
Uh,
so,
uh,
very in many ways,
um,
because these were just volunteers.
It wasn't a very high tech war.
And Roma Campo,
um,
had a lot of footage about it's very load hat war and basically this is the war
that we see and for whom devout hose,
um,
just one or two people walking through the mountains,
just trudging along talking to small groups of people,
um,
completely kind of a local initiative,
and not just in the cities but also in the countryside.
And we should remember that informed about how essentially behind the lines they
have behind the enemy lines.
So they keep,
you know,
one possibility would be to go back to the Spanish republic is to cross the
enemy line and go back and join with the main forces.
But the people that we see for whom the bell tolls are with the gorillas who
would be in conditions such as these.
Um,
so this is the,
the,
the kind of the iconic images,
uh,
of just civilly and is fighting to defend the Spanish republic.
But,
um,
the reason that it was such a,
big global event,
uh,
was that it was an actually an incredibly high tech war.
So it is a very important link between the first world war and the Second World
War.
And we know that the alliances in the Spanish civil war,
Germany and Italy,
we go onto become the axes power in the second world war.
So a very,
very important link between those two.
Great World Wars itself to spending.
So war was a world war or saw a skim and the number of international
participants.
Um,
so,
um,
Thames for important,
the Republicans actually use trackers,
um,
but the fascist had real tasks and we see them,
the tans in full force.
Um,
and this is the follow image of the triumph of the tanks,
the fascist,
um,
entering Madrid March,
1939 and the next month the republic,
the Spanish republic surrender to the fascist.
Um,
so we know they all come very well.
I was basically a very short war,
um,
but because they were defending a lit,
an elected government,
um,
the international sentiment was on the side of the Spanish republic.
And this is a very famous painting by the Spanish,
uh,
paint we row.
But you know,
this,
that the language was actually not Spanish a day.
Let's Lisbon French,
uh,
because he couldn't stay in Spain anymore after the outbreak of the war,
so he had to flee to France.
And this was actually an exhibition in Paris,
so that's why the language was in French.
And friends will actually come up a little bit informed about hose,
um,
as well as friends.
So it's kind of an interesting side reference that we'll be talking about next
time.
But um,
lost and lots of images of international aid.
Um,
once again,
mostly very non military was looking people,
uh,
giving a two,
two to the Spanish public.
So the,
these were others in London,
um,
just giving medical supplies.
Um,
but,
um,
the Americans were there in full force and this is the link.
Abraham Lincoln Brigade,
um,
they serve,
they're the Ashley the best equipped,
uh,
volunteers.
Um,
there were pictures of volunteers from Poland and they actually,
they look kind of sad to begin with without even without the fighting.
Um,
but the Americans were very well equipped and they look very healthy and ready
to fight.
Um,
and they were also very,
very young,
so it was very glamorous war in one sense because of all the young people who
were fighting.
So,
and women there is,
we can see.
So,
um,
the Lincoln Brigade and um,
in the beginning of the war there was lots of musical entertainment and it
seemed like fun.
Um,
initially it quickly stopped being fun as we can tell from the novel.
so Hemingway was there,
he was a walker as bonding.
It was covering the war with the Republicans here and this rare image of him,
Ashley,
um,
holding a gun,
he wasn't supposed to fight and I don't think he actually fought,
but just in case he needed to have someday.
Um,
so,
um,
it all loose suggests that one way to think about the novel,
uh,
would be the thing about,
um,
uh,
kind of divide in the novel or kind of structural principle.
Um,
in terms of voluntary association versus in Voluntary Association,
um,
voluntary association.
Obviously the international brigades,
um,
all these people did not have to fight in a war.
They are voluntarily put themselves in danger in order to,
um,
for political reason.
Um,
so very much voluntary association in this loss of glory and honor and pleasure.
from that PRI,
from that.
Um,
and then on the opposite side with the involuntary association,
we get labeled as foreigners.
The Americans get labeled this thorough knows Robert Jordan gets labeled as
foreigner is not even given the dignity of being an American is referred to as
the English,
the English.
Uh,
so they even,
they,
they get this national identity wrong,
but it doesn't really matter.
He's just one of those foreigners.
So foreign,
there's a kind of involuntary association,
a generic type.
Um,
and then the ultimate involuntary association would be the company of the debt.
It's a very large company and very few of us really want a ready to join them
right now,
but we're put in that company.
Um,
so,
uh,
going back to done obviously,
and,
but also going back to,
um,
pretty much all the texts that we've been talking about all semester.
So,
uh,
we've been talking about this phenomenon of involuntary association in terms of
individual and type.
So just want to go back very quickly to refresh your memory about all this text,
um,
to have and have not.
Um,
Harry's in voluntary association would be with all the other half knots and
there were plenty of drum during the great depression.
Uh,
that would be the involuntary,
so the station for him.
Uh,
but luckily for him,
um,
he actually can have,
can qualify that in voluntary association when he's mediated by the presence of
Murray,
when he becomes,
um,
you know,
this really wonderful and long lasting,
not perishing figure in her mind.
Uh,
and when he is mediated in contrast to Richard Gordon in the Fitzgerald stories,
rich boy and Bernice,
perhaps her hair,
um,
we have the involuntary association through type.
So rich boy,
um,
and,
and hunter,
he has an involuntary,
the association with the title of the story rich boy,
but he deviated so much.
I mean,
he's such an extreme example that he's almost a deviation and Bernie's reversed
to a much more engine type,
the native American.
Um,
so they all have a kind of qualify in voluntary association to the immediate
surroundings.
Um,
and as I laid on,
which we just finished discussing is Faulkner's version of to have and have not.
Um,
and Ashley there,
uh,
it seems that the constant of have not,
is most,
um,
to nations and,
and in many ways Victoria's,
um,
at the end triumphant at the end in the sense that Dow really,
is in voluntarily couldn't find her Jackson.
Um,
here's an involuntary,
so Jolen in,
in s and saying in a mental institution,
um,
so,
that is in any ways Faulkner's is the most pessimistic,
um,
of those three writers today.
Um,
well look at a complicated,
uh,
seven full implementation,
um,
and talking about hose.
Um,
and we won't be talking about all of them today.
So this pretty much is the,
uh,
the pattern,
the structure for the,
the nets for lecturers.
Um,
but just want to give you a sense of what were we talking about,
individual versus type,
obviously,
um,
the voluntary versus involuntary and given the fact that the setting is Spain,
uh,
Thoren versus not foreign.
Um,
and,
uh,
the question of language brings up the question though,
for the literacy and illiteracy.
Um,
and the,
the relation between the distant home and the slight environment is going to be
very important because to the United States actually has quite an important
presence in this novel.
So with the relation between the United States and Spain,
um,
and something that we've been talking about all the way through the comics,
this is tragic.
And finally to half and half not so,
um,
all of these,
we'll be talking about in the next two weeks.
But,
um,
today we'll concentrate on the concept of involuntary foreigners.
Um,
and it turns out that they actually two classes of involuntary foreigners,
one completely counted until then.
We would think that the involvement Turi foreigners would just be American.
This,
they are the obvious foreigners.
Um,
and Hemingway gives us multiple instances of when one could be an involuntary
for and that,
but I think that,
um,
he is an astute enough,
reader of the future,
um,
and of the Sioux,
the global dimension of the Spanish civil war,
to know that the Spanish colossal will be involuntary foreign is in their own
country.
Um,
this is happening all the time now.
lots of,
lots of people are involuntary fallenness in the country.
It is,
uh,
one of the most common phenomenon in the 20th first century.
Um,
and,
um,
Hemingway is portraying some of that trending spend,
the civil war because of the phenomenon of print illiteracy and because of
technological illiteracy that against very,
very common.
So,
uh,
let's just start on the American side.
Um,
we know that Hemingway is actually very,
very good when he uses it and being considerate of those of us who don't know
Spanish or who just know a few words in Spanish,
um,
bad.
He,
when he uses a Spanish word or phrase,
who would give us the translation almost right away.
So we have no trouble understanding the Spanish in the novel.
Um,
but he does have this interesting,
um,
stylistic innovation of inflecting the English language in the direction of
Spanish.
So the classic example is,
um,
the,
an idiomatic expression,
how are you call is live,
what's your name?
Uh,
we don't go around asking people how your caught because Spanish is not really
the reference point for us.
And not,
not,
not for most of us.
At any rate in this country,
uh,
no,
not yet.
But in Spain,
that's how English,
that's the formed English would take even in your own head if what you would ask
people all the time,
there's Como Se yama was that um,
how you call literally translated from that.
Um,
and is the more formal expression,
right?
So it's not the two is not to someone that you know,
well is the more formal expression addressing someone,
um,
that maybe you're meeting for the first time someone who was older,
more fonts showing more respect for the person,
distance from the person.
Um,
what is it,
fat of this kind of English,
um,
not in Spanish,
not translate it into Spanish words,
but translated into Spanish syntax.
Um,
is,
is not wood,
it is not the actual translation into Spanish worst,
but translation using the syntactical structure of Spanish.
I think that there are many effects that depending on the degree of your degree
of knowledge was managed really.
Uh,
it could be irritating.
I imagine actually for someone who's,
you know,
for Spanish speaker.
Um,
but I think that for people who actually have a kind of very slight acquaintance
with Spanish,
um,
the fact is kind of a double alienation.
Um,
we sue take note of the fact that um,
this is an idiomatic English.
Um,
and we,
so we're struggling to kind of thing of the Spanish equivalent for that.
That would be the origin for the English phrase.
Um,
in any case it makes us aware of the way of how English actually is not
translatable with for word into Spanish,
right.
How is,
what's your name is not,
cannot be translated word for word into Spanish.
So it highlights the non translatability of English and the fact that they
really are very important cross cultural barriers,
not least of all in language as the cross cultural barrier.
Certain things cannot gather across easily.
They cannot get across without modification.
Um,
so Hemingway gives us no illusion that you can fit easily into,
um,
of a different environment.
Um,
gives us no illusion that there could be this immediate community in between
people from different cultural and linguistic backgrounds.
Um,
I think that this double effect of this double elimination is also going to make
us aware of sometimes how strange our own,
how strange the English language,
uh,
with beer.
Um,
so you know,
every time you know more than one language.
So if you aware of,
of how each of those languages,
um,
how,
how each one is actually quite strange in retooling instances.
Um,
so,
um,
it,
it makes,
it makes everyone is sort of involuntary foreigner,
even though you're still at home really,
you still a native speaker of one language.
Um,
the fact that you aware of other languages and to wish you all native language
cannot be automatically translated,
uh,
makes you almost authority or a slight foreigner in your own native language.
Um,
so,
but this is a very mild and really not painful form.
I think of being a foreigner.
Um,
things Scott start getting more painful,
um,
very fast actually and informed about hose and the people still joke about it.
So here is um,
Robert Jordan talking to the Russian in general because I don't actually know
how it's pronounced in Russian.
Um,
but they were talking about the bridge and we know that Robert is supposed to
blow up the bridge so they were actually talking business.
Um,
and Robert Jordan is assuring the Russian general that he knows exactly what to
do.
That he's a very good,
he's very,
is a very good engineer.
He is very good with,
with explosives.
Um,
and this is what God as I believe you do.
You know how the of the bridge,
I will not make you.
And the low speech now does have a drink so much talking makes me very thirsty.
Conrad,
hold them.
You have a funny name in Spanish,
correct?
Holton,
how do you say goes in Spanish?
Conrad general host say goes grinning,
making the sound deep in his Strout as though hawking with a bad co host,
he crow come right Henry Hill holds.
If I had known how they would pronounce,
how they pronounce calls in Spanish,
I would pick me up a better name before I come to war here.
So,
um,
the Spanish g and j sounds are pronounced as edge.
So that's why it is especially this concerning when you have a combination of
those as income income in general clothes.
I can't even say it now,
I'm so confused.
Um,
that,
um,
it gets,
it is really totally alienating your own name becomes unrecognizable in a
foreign language.
Um,
it doesn't happen,
you know,
most of the time it doesn't happen,
but it just,
so,
um,
it,
it just so happens that in this one instance there really is kind of a double
alienation going on.
Uh,
four goals.
Um,
so what does it mean when you own name is not pronounceable,
there's just no equivalent sung in Spanish.
Um,
it could be,
you know,
really innocent and completely innocuous,
a trivial occurrence.
Um,
but for something like that,
one is tented oh one is almost in voluntarily tended to read more meaning,
um,
into that there's just no Spanish equivalent.
So my own identity in that language,
there's no room,
there's no place,
there's just no slot that is waiting for me that I can fit in.
There's just no sound that will reproduce unnecessary sound in English.
Um,
so it really raises the question of what kind of a place Robert Jordan could
have in the Spanish community if there's no,
um,
if there's no linguistic,
if there's no fanatic slot for him in the Spanish language,
would there be a social slots for him in that Spanish community?
Would there be a functional slots for him in that community?
He has some very,
very well defined function.
He's there to blow up the bridge and as long as he sticks to that very limited
function palliate okay.
Room for someone who will blow up bridges and leave.
Um,
but the thing is people can actually just confine themselves to that very,
very narrow definition.
Um,
it would be unbearable actually to be no more than just someone who's there to
blow up the bridge and do nothing else.
You can just be,
have that very,
very narrow existence.
So Robert Jordan has got to have some relations to the people and once he
wanders away from that very straight,
very narrow definition,
things will get problematic.
Um,
and that's why there's so much tension between him and the Spanish.
so one other instance of in voluntary association in front being involuntary,
uh,
foreign foreigner,
um,
and the worst foreigners is actually used by the Spanish a lot,
partly to insult,
uh,
Robert.
Um,
so Pablo is actually the one where,
who's especially aggressive when it comes to that.
It was a thought on their own with us who make the explosions.
Pablo said,
do you know him?
What is he called?
I do not remember.
It was a very rare name.
What did he look like?
He was fair as you are.
Not as tall and with large hands and a broken nose.
Kashkin rough vigilance.
That would be Kashkin yes,
to Pablo.
It was a very rainy,
something like that.
What became of him he steps since April.
Um,
a number of things.
We actually don't know if Pablo remembers the name cash can one now.
He,
for all we know,
he might actually be able to remember that name very well.
Um,
they don't have foreign news every day among them and task in this knowledge and
the hot names.
Remember he probably knows that.
And um,
he is emphatic about not knowing the name,
not being able to recall the name.
Even when offered the named,
he refuses to repeat the name,
something like that.
Just a generic foreigner.
Um,
so nothing can be more aggressive in regretfully by way of talking dismissively
about Kashkin as the foot gettable foreign that because it's just a generic type
is just there who made the explosions.
Um,
so in all his ways he's making this forgettable,
um,
unimportant,
probably not like foreigner.
Um,
the predecessor for Robert Jordan and this will kind of unforeseen consequence
of making cash can the predecessor for Robert and public probably doesn't know
that,
but cash can actually had died.
Um,
and we know later on that he had died by killing himself.
He just couldn't,
he,
his job is to,
um,
is to blow up bridges or the blowup trains.
Um,
but he should terrify of doing it.
And so he killed himself,
uh,
which,
Robert Normally knows.
So a combination of deliberate aggression from Pablo,
um,
make turning the Florida into a generic type into which both Kashkin and Robert
would be inserted,
um,
that deliberate aggression from Pablo combine with a circumstance that he
probably wouldn't have known that cashed in his bed at this point.
All of this Ma Dad for an a not just a foreigner,
but dad for the,
the sort of scripted future for Robert Jordan.
Um,
it's not just that foreigners cannot assimilate into the community,
but they also have a tendency to dive fairly soon.
Um,
that seems to be the forecasts for Robert Jordan.
So,
um,
we don't know if this forecast,
uh,
will actually become reality.
It's just a possibility at this point.
Um,
but it's a very,
very,
um,
emphatic,
a possibility that is underscore numerous time Ashley by other people.
Every time Kashkin comes up,
how he died.
Um,
and the fact that he's like,
Robyn,
in many ways,
their hair a there,
um,
all those things come up.
Uh,
so it is,
it is the kind of a signature is kind of a structural,
uh,
signature and narratives signature in terms of the punctuation,
um,
that Hemingway puts into his novel.
Um,
others,
places when we started wonder,
um,
is the similar fate awaiting Robert Jordan similar to Kashkin?
Um,
so the company off the debt,
I think it's fair to say is never very far as always on the horizons in phase,
not even on the horizon is a looming presence,
um,
in that community and this looming presence,
especially for foreigners and that community.
Um,
so,
um,
that's probably,
that's pretty bad for Americans is we don't actually see a lot of Americans when
you see one,
a rubber Jolen.
Um,
so,
um,
it's pretty bad.
Um,
the signs and omens are not good.
but it seems that the signs and omens are also not great for the Spanish as
well.
Um,
and we can look at the ways in which,
um,
they are involuntary foreigners in their own countries.
And actually Robert Jordan is also quite aggressive and um,
making sure that the Spanish can sometimes feel like they don't quite own the
own country or they,
they know,
they don't know how things are done in their own country.
Um,
Robin handed the rubber hits a piece of paper to prove his credentials,
which if necessary,
given the fact that nobody knows anything about him.
So you know,
how would people know that he's on their side?
So he has,
um,
pieces of documents to prove that he is in fact,
well credentialed.
So he handed it to the man who opened it,
looked at it dolefully and turned it in his hands so he cannot read rubbish.
Children know that.
Look in the CEO,
he said the old man pointed to the CEO and a man with a carbine studying it,
turning it in his fingers.
Was the,
is that,
have you never seen it?
No,
there are two.
Is that Robert Jordan?
One is the Sim,
the service of the military intelligence.
The other one is the general staff.
Yes,
I have seen that seal before,
but here,
no one commands but me,
the ones that song.
So they obviously has a struggle for authority here.
It is a shock to us,
um,
that Pablo inside all the people that we see in his novel,
all the Spanish that they all ill veteran,
um,
bad.
Um,
and usually we don't even have to specify as print illiteracy.
but here it seems especially important to uh,
it out because they've very literate in and other science.
Uh,
we know that I was Sammo Ashaway speaks,
um,
a classical,
Spanish Castilian Spanish,
which is very pure and it's the language of literature of course.
Vedo um,
so,
but yeah,
actually very literate in the sense that of having a very,
very distinguished literary tradition behind them,
but oral tradition so they can re writing.
Um,
but obviously in the 20,
in the 20th century,
early than the 20th century,
um,
not to be able to read and write is a tremendous liability.
So right there,
this one strike against all these Spanish who cannot read their own language in
writing.
It is robbing the foreigner who can actually we Spanish writing Spanish script.
Um,
but there's another level of illiteracy and a print illiteracy and it goes even
beyond language.
Um,
in the fact that they are two CEO's,
uh,
on that document Pablo recognizes and one only one of the CEOs,
he doesn't recognize the other one.
He doesn't recognize the other one because he's not high up enough on the
military hierarchy to have come across the other CEO's before.
Um,
so in many ways it is Robert's way of putting him down showing that he actually
has more knowledge of the military infrastructure than Pablo does.
So that's why Pablo is very solid and way responses and completely
understandable response is no one commands here but me.
Um,
Pablos hope and as they,
this is very interesting whole,
um,
there will be tested and I think some degree supported in the novel,
is that it doesn't really matter how high up you are on the general military
infrastructure that in many ways people who actually know the community well,
we'll be able to have command that community.
I'm just saying this now as possible or like,
um,
but suddenly the contest of authority between Pablo,
uh,
and,
Robert will be played out throughout the entire novel.
One of the most important structural features of this novel.
Um,
another,
uh,
but print illiteracy,
um,
is,
is both very nameable.
Um,
and you know,
is it basically defines who you are.
Um,
but it's,
it's kind of a general condition,
but they have more specific instances of illiteracy that I would call it
technological literacy.
Um,
and it has to do with the high tech warfare,
um,
that we're seeing,
is also a central feature of the Spanish civil war.
So he is talking about,
um,
and I found myself actually looking for images for lots of military websites to
find the images for,
for,
for this,
uh,
this or weapons.
Um,
how is uh,
is Louis Gun Robert Jordan thought,
do you know anything about machine gun?
He asked,
Oh man,
now the sales down on nothing.
He has an instance of Hemingway doing instantaneous translation now that Sam or
nothing and Dow to the Gypsy that they filed with much repetitive and become so
hot.
The Barrows turn the barracks,
turn,
burn the hand,
the touches it,
the Gypsies are proudly,
unless they jam,
run out of ammunition or get so hot,
they melt.
Robert Jordan said in English,
what do you say?
[inaudible] asked him nothing and wish all of them said I was only looking into
the future in English.
Um,
this is a fairly aggressive moment on the side of Robin.
Every time someone switches in the language,
they know,
the other person doesn't understand.
Uh,
his thing there was intentionality is similar school aggression.
Um,
but we'll stay away from that for a moment and just look at the Louis Gun.
this was a major innovation,
actually train the World War One.
It started in world war one.
Um,
and this is a very complicated piece of machinery.
So,
um,
people,
we,
nobody will have a kind of intuitive,
um,
command of this weapon.
And so,
uh,
here is just one instance of the Louis Gun drill.
You have to learn to use the gun and we can see is a very,
very big,
um,
is very unwieldy.
It's heavy.
Um,
and also it,
you just can't hold it in your hand and you have to put it on your shoulder and
carry it around.
Um,
it really is a major hindrance,
um,
to any kind of movement.
And here is,
is,
um,
an image of how inconvenient Ashley,
how will the pain and is actually to use that gun.
Um,
it is a weapon that Ashley quit create springs producers,
that facial expression,
um,
on the person who you trying to use that gallon.
Um,
so it is understandable,
uh,
bad either Robert Jordan himself.
Um,
when take note when he knows is that isn't Louis Gun is not just any ordinary
weaponry.
Um,
this is special kinds of equipment and the signals,
um,
a certain level of fighting as soon as scale warfare when the Louis gun is
involved.
And it's because it's signals Isolon scale finding that is no longer strictly
though go affair,
no,
no longer,
strictly based on local local knowledge or intuitive use of small weapons.
Um,
I think that because of all these reasons,
um,
that he was suddenly switched to English as if I'm just giving himself the,
the,
um,
the license to think out loud to himself in a different language at that point.
Um,
he doesn't think very highly of the Louis Gun.
even though it's such an impressive looking at cumbersome a weapon,
um,
it actually,
you can jam or run out of ammunition and get so hot,
they melt.
So,
you know,
it's not a great weapon to use.
Ora.
Um,
that's part of the reason he's saying this in English,
so that the Spanish when,
no,
all these drawbacks,
this high tech a weapon.
Um,
but also that people who use the Louis gun really have a different relation to
the future than people who don't.
Right.
It's similar in,
in,
uh,
um,
siblings setting in the 21st century.
People who don't have a computer at this point,
who,
people who've never used a computer,
very different relation to the future,
into the present than people who do it really is a sharp dividing line.
So in the contest of the Spanish civil war,
people who've never seen Louis Kahn,
who's never handled one have a different relation to the future.
So the gun itself is a kind of a door keeper.
Um,
various people are admitted and having a viable relation to the future and
various people are banned from having a viable relation diffuser or they have a
three to manage a in a relation to the future.
So the gun is the door,
keep her.
Um,
and the English language as far as Robert understands it,
um,
it's lined up with the gun in that way.
Um,
there's um,
the,
the gun is one is on the ground,
um,
and this another weapon that has wings that is also very important to the
Spanish civil war.
And we see,
um,
the next installment and,
of this technological illiteracy on the side of the Spanish in this exchange.
Hi,
the evening sky,
three monoplanes in v formation showing my nude and still very at that height
with it still was sun passing unbelievably quickly across the sky.
The motors now strobing steadily hours.
They seem so Robert Jordan his head.
But knew that at that height,
you never could be assured they are markers of samples that rather Jolen cause I
put the glasses on and ensure instantly,
but who prefer now to it make no difference to him who they were tonight.
And if it pleased the Oh man to have them be hours,
he did not want to take them away.
Now as they move outside to us that go via,
that did not look to be the green red wing tip,
low wing Russian kind of version of the Boeing p 32.
That is Spanish called Moscow's.
You cannot see that colors.
The cut was wrong.
No,
it was a fascist patrol coming home.
So knowledge of airplanes,
um,
knowledge that Ashley,
I think most of us in this room,
how they don't have.
Um,
but anyway,
um,
this is the Moscow,
so Boeing,
Peter the two.
Um,
and um,
you know,
I don't know what else to say about it is that it looks kind of primitive.
Um,
and um,
but that's,
um,
Ashley,
I did read somewhere that they,
that this is the last of that.
Uh,
there were various previous incarnations of Boeing p 29 of something,
and this is the laws and then Boeing to stop developing this,
those citizens last of the line.
Um,
if we look at actually the German planes,
the high angles,
very,
very effective bombers,
um,
they actually look much more impressive than the Moscow's.
Um,
you can see that this is a plane that anyone can see,
can do serious damage.
Um,
and here is the Italian Fiat and Osama is to be forgiven for mistaking the
Italian Fiat for the Boeing p 32 because they actually,
they assured,
um,
and they're kind of clumsy looking.
Um,
and we can see right away,
um,
that even though this is the Spanish civil war,
the Nazi insignia is there.
So that really is the second world war intruding into the Spanish civil war.
No question that having ways using the word fascist in three deliberate way,
um,
and this is a much more effective version.
Uh,
oh,
the Spanish bombings.
Um,
we'll be talking about,
uh,
of this in the actual destruction,
um,
of,
of some of the people in this novel,
what the bombers were the Italian bombs can do to local population.
Um,
but I just want to go back,
um,
to that phrase about looking into the future.
In English.
We've talked a lot about tomorrows and the future,
right?
Beginning with the sound and the fury and the way in which,
um,
the tomorrow,
of Benji and the tomorrow of Jason and the tomorrow,
uh,
of Quentin,
um,
not in many ways for impels versions of the present that is not as a future that
one can inhabit.
Um,
and here it raises the question of whether the future is in,
can be inhabited by Spanish speakers who don't know English at all.
Um,
in this context,
it's just no way,
um,
that the Spanish could know that this local community,
if they can really read Spanish,
um,
in writing this farm was no way they can read Spanish,
reads the future in English.
Um,
but it also doesn't feel like this is the future that even if you were able to
read that you would want to live in,
even if you have the ability to read that future,
even if that future is written,
written large by Louis Gun and by the planes that is a very legible future
written on the sky and on the ground,
even though there's such a legible future and you can read it,
it might still not be a future that you would want to move into,
not a future that you would want to inhabit.
So this is a way in which there's also a kind of a double alienation going up.
The Spanish are banned from that future because they simply cannot read it.
It is illegible to them.
Robert Jordan who can read just fine is also,
um,
in many ways an outsider to that future because it's not anything that he would
like to live and it's not a world that he would like to live in.
Um,
and I just want to give you to find the images,
um,
of,
what happens to the Spanish,
uh,
historically,
because of the use of bombers,
um,
in the Spanish civil war,
this is,
um,
the most famous town.
It was completely destroyed by Italian farmers.
Uh,
Gwen,
they can,
and this is the famous because of painting.
Um,
and uh,
it is,
it's,
um,
w we can see this is really the kind of the response of a low tech population to
high tech warfare.
Um,
you just never seen anything like that before.
So it is nightmarish.
It is real,
um,
in a sense that the world has turned to a different kinds of reality.
Um,
it's just,
it has no relation to reality as you know,
and then that's why it is so real.
And that's why cubism is in any ways,
um,
in response to,
uh,
the surreal scenarios congeal out by the high tech weaponry of,
of world wars.
Um,
so we'll come back to this and talk more about,
um,
basically the phenomenon of dying both in isolation but also dying as a result
of something that is lodged and is coming at you.